pierre desproges vous avez décidé à
votre tour d'écrire à une haute autorité
oui parce que je suis indignée monnaie
c'est une lettre ouverte à monseigneur
lustiger cher seigneur qu'il me soit
permis de m'indigner ici véhémentement
contre les insupportables attaques
portées régulièrement à la télévision à
mon athéisme militants par vos camarades
de goupillon il est intolérable
deux siècles après la séparation de
l'église et de l'état dans un pays qui
poussent la laïcité officielle au rang
d'institution nationale que des anti hat
et hystérique accapare l'antenne de la
télévision le dimanche matin avec des
émissions intitulée j'ai site la messe
du dimanche dans laquelle les minorités
at et non priante non bigot temps tu es
mal bêtifiante sont méprisés et bafoué
et je pèse mes mots au profit de
grotesque manifestation incantatoire
d'une secte en rêve dans le monothéisme
avoué est une véritable insulte à darwin
religion gréco romaine et à ma soeur qui
fait bouddhistes dans un bordel de kuala
lumpur
voilà je précise que j'envoie par ce
même courrier une copie de cette lettre
à dieu et que ça va chier